have two separate categories you feel me  one is for fun and the other is for  wifey and you gotta understand that  those women who are wearing these short  dresses they're showing off their body  and all of that they all go into the fun  category like us man them we can you  know how okay let's put it this way that  women I'm sure you've all been in the  club before and a random guy approached  you and like you kind of can smell that  he's some kind of creep you feel me  right Magnum can do the same thing we  can smell when there's a hoe up like  talking to us can we not use this type  of terminology like can we not refer to  women as like hoes  I'm not asking can we use other words  we're not referring to all women as I  was referring to hoses